hello everyone welcome to
this causal ml research panel at the msr
research summit i'm adith i'm a
researcher in the redmond lab i study
causal reasoning and reinforcement
learning with applications in user
interactive systems
i'm most excited by the potential for
counter factual reasoning for those who
have read the book of why this is the
rung three counterfactuals
in enabling new high-stakes rl
applications
msr has a long history of research and
causality decision making and machine
learning right from david heckerman's
work in the late 80s and early 90s
during the early days of msr chris meeks
influential work on causal explanations
max chickering's work on causal
discovery and learning in bayesian nets
and almost three decades later causal ml
research is going strong and powering
many impactful applications today
so this panel should give a few glimpses
of the kinds of research that's
happening across msrdaps so we will not
attempt to give a comprehensive picture
of everything that's going on but we
will hear diverse perspectives from lab
members in cambridge uk beijing china
and redmond usa
first a quick round of introductions
let's go around the room in alphabetical
order daniel do you please want to
introduce yourself and what you work on
thanks adith
my name is sandra mcduff
and i work in the hugh group at msr
which stands for human understanding and
empathy and we focus on
understanding human behavior in
different forms
through measurement of
physiology as well as
observable measurement of expression
and i'm very interested in causal
reasoning for the ability
ability to build models that better
generalize to observations that maybe
haven't been seen in the past um and
this is something that's often very
challenging
when um considering human behavior there
may be behaviors that you've never seen
before or that are very rare
and also the interpretability that those
models offer the ability to or be able
to explain why decisions were made by a
model
and understand what the model has
learned from large sets of data
next javier do you want to please tell
us about your background and your work
hello everyone and thanks for the
invitation to this panel
my name is javier gonzalez i'm a
researcher in the
microsoft research lab here in cambridge
in the in the uk
and i'm part of the health intelligence
group
where our goal is to build
[Music]
robust and trustworthy machine learning
methods to improve
the way
we do we do medicine i'm particularly
interested in causal inferences uh
as a way to encode a mechanistic
understanding of biological processes of
interest or or or
medical knowledge that we have about
about the our problems in in the model
that we use to solve prediction problems
or problems in which we we are
interested in computing some some
specific
causal quantity obviously this involves
a few things uh recently about
counterfactuals is one of them
making predictions in in domains in
which
we have an observed data in which we
have trainer models and in particular
interested as well in how we can
quantify the uncertainty of all these
quantities whether they are predictions
or or causal or causal quantities so we
can do data fusion and all sorts of
things with the with the data that we
have and finally justin uh do you want
to tell us what your journey to msr was
like and what do you work on
yeah
so
hello so i'm a researcher
in the data analytics research team
in the microsoft research asia
i'm
currently conducting the research on
autoinsets
aims at automatically discovering
interesting and meaningful data patterns
and to facilitate the exploratory or
predictive data analysis but i'm also
very recently focusing on conducting
research on causality
and explicitly ai to provide deeper
insights provide the explanations and
action suggestions to bridge the gap
towards the automatic and robust
decision making
yeah yeah so thanks everyone for
uh joining this panel uh maybe the
most like top of the mind question i
have is um what is the biggest
opportunity you see for causal ml
research to impact the world like what
is your vision of the future and how can
causal research enable it uh i'm
particularly curious to hear javier's
thoughts on this first
thank you thank you thank you very much
abee um
yeah so i
i
i think i'm very fortunate to have been
in in a team in in which we use the cos
lml uh every day so
the world of healthcare gives us a lot
of opportunities uh of impact for for
this type of technique so we can think
about some of them for instance the the
estimation of individual treatment
effects um and and how that's translate
in
counter factors that can inform
what
type of treatment we should be giving to
patients or when we think about
counterfactuals how we can do data
augmentation so we can improve um
the way we do image
classification or the way we can make
predictions of disease
given some biomarkers of
patients in in populations in which
the models that we are training uh
haven't haven't seen the data
so we we see cos lml everywhere in the
in the in the healthcare domain and it's
a it's an exciting field uh where where
we can apply this type of techniques in
in different ways in in ways in which
causal
inference can help a standard machine
learning method that we were using to do
predictions and also in the way machine
learning can inform and can help a
standard or or causal inference in the
way we we compute the
causal quantities i see the two
directions very relevant in the field
and and justin i know that offline when
we were exchanging emails you really
sketched out a very compelling vision
for the future of data analytics uh do
you want to share yeah sure so
from the uh very high level
uh in order to
make the causal machine learning for
analytics data analytics uh applicable i
think there are three major challenges
the first i think first of all is the
democratizing causal concept into the
domain of
business intelligence or data analytics
and i think the second one is uh how to
acquire the appropriate course of
knowledge so in different business
domains people have different domain
knowledge but most of them are i think
uh stored in mind
in a partial way or pieces how to
leverage the data driven approach
combined with the domain knowledge to
come up with a reasonable cause of
knowledge is that i think the second
challenge
and the last thing i think is also about
the caveat of adopting using the
causality so from my point of view
causality is also a type of
uh way to representing the assumptions
so you can using causal knowledge to
conduct further analysis uh towards some
conclusion but you should also always
keep in mind that all these conclusions
are built upon some assumptions and
there might be some uh
risks uh if you fully trust that yeah
that's my point of view thank you
i think justin
addressed a few of the opportunities but
also the challenges in the applying
causality and data analytics i'm curious
daniel what are the opportunities and
the challenges you are foreseeing in in
some of the causal ml research that
you're doing
yeah i think there's a lot of
opportunities in the
human computer interaction domain
generally
in building models that can um explain
why decisions were made and help and
that i think that's essential for
um having
algorithms with humans in the loop when
you're when you have humans interacting
with systems um being able to do causal
um inference and and modeling i think is
is is really critical and nowhere more
so than in in safety critical situations
whether it's you know humans interacting
with self-driving vehicles or or robots
that's where i think there's you know
really big potential to
make those systems much more practical
and safer importantly
do you want to plug the causal city work
that you've contributed to because yeah
uniquely
yeah so one thing that we're working on
is using high fidelity simulations to
enable some of this modeling and
take a lot of causal structure learning
which has been
done on
relatively sort of contrived and simple
simulation scenarios
into
scenarios that are much more similar to
the ones that we have in real life like
self-driving vehicles so we have a
we've developed a simulated environment
where we can control causal
relationships very carefully
and that allows us to to generate data
sets to test um causal for instance
causal structure learning uh models and
and also do sort of counter factual
reasoning
with um the combination of of you know
computer vision and and inferring you
know doing perception as well as um
causal inference
i guess it's alluding to uh so i'm
sensing a trend now in in the responses
where we are switching from the
opportunities to the challenges and what
we can build today to
get after those challenges uh i'm
actually quite curious to know uh
what what makes research in causal ml
methods hard like why is this
challenging and why is now the time to
go after it
um
daniel let's go in reverse order
sure yeah to build on what i um just
talked about i think what makes has made
it hard in for instance a computer
vision domain in the past is that
you're building data sets where you have
causal relationships has been very
challenging you often have a very long
tail um of you know observations of rare
events and you just don't have the
ability to to
build strong um you know
data sets with with rich causal
structure um because
those images might be gathered more
opportunistically scraped from the
internet or you know different locations
so i think simulation really you know
offers a lot of opportunities for us to
um
go much further beyond that and and
we've only recently had
you know the ability to build these high
fidelity simulations as well as generate
the types of the amounts of data that we
really need to to make them useful so
that's one thing and what we're trying
to do with the causal city work is to
try to make that more accessible to
other people as well so to to make it uh
an open um platform that people can you
know generate their own
data sets with different um causal
relationships
uh how about javier do you also see the
role like is it powerful simulators that
are unblocking these uh
individual treatment effects style uh
causal quantities that we might go after
in health yeah it's a
i think it's a
it's a bit harder in the in the health
domain um to think about simulators of
of a patient
i think one of the
harder things that we that we face when
when try to solve um
problems related with causal inference
in the healthcare domain is that we are
never sure about whether we are making
the right assumptions or not because
there is this endless loop of trying to
model a
[Music]
medical or a biological phenomenon
trying to learn uh from from the
modeling that we have done
collecting more data and trying to uh
redefine the hypotheses that that we are
making in some cases you can you can you
can you can you see you can use
simulators but uh
when we think about the effects of of a
drug in uh in the response of a patient
um we are working on a very high level
of granularity of how the biological
processes are are happening um so it's
uh
so the the
the way of operating by
uh
writing a causal graph uh sometimes it
is very hard sometimes we we know a part
of the graph we need to discover other
parts of the graph in order to make sure
that we are making the right assumptions
are computing the the right quantities
and obviously also the the scarcity of
data and the different modalities of
data we have that we have to to combine
the different confounding effects that
you may have in the in the different
type of data so that's also very very
challenging that builds on on top of
what i'd say
yeah this uh loop that you described
between like constantly refining
assumptions as you
uh as it touches the real world and go
back and redo it it also ties to
something justin just mentioned earlier
which is that you know causality is
really you can think of it as a way to
express domain knowledge and to be more
precise about our assumptions and be
able to
re like blame a sign which assumptions
might be wrong and and go back and fix
it and i'm curious justin um in data
analytics um
like are we making progress is that is
now the right time to be building these
uh vi tools to enable
easier iterations through this really
hard loop
uh i think the recent years there's a
very good time
uh it's a very good opportunity so
there's an interesting story here so i i
will start from the
uh explainable data analytics
so it is basically about the scenarios
where users post and seek answers to the
why question so when users see some bar
charts some sales marketing data i don't
want to
say why why this happens
and this is a typical scenario in the bi
domain business intelligence and
actually there have been some product
tools
aimed to answer such kind of white
question such as the cavaliers explained
data or microsoft power bis
explain increased decrease
however
these approaches currently are
association
approaches associated but not causal so
therefore sometimes there will be some
funny results since users somewhat uh
have the intention to seek for the
causal effect of answers so in my
opinion so acquiring causal knowledge is
the primary step before conducting such
kind of data analysis
but in the bi domain there are two very
uh
two challenges the first is many data
collected in the bi domain are causally
insufficient
so the uh data collections they may not
be sufficient uh so there are a lot of
the latent confounders there and the
second thing is many uh data sets are
stored in the database in terms of
multiple tables subtables and when they
join together so there are some
deterministic relationships among the
variables so so they are not they're no
longer still cast by determinist as a
result the faithfulness assumption no
longer hold in many cases so in summary
when we want to adopt the classical
causal structure learning algorithms uh
just a reminder
just a reminder that the causal
sufficiency the faithfulness and
assumptions
usually are often uh no longer hold so
we will have to come up with some noble
ideas to address those challenges i
think this is an interesting opportunity
and also challenges for us to conduct
causal machine learning for data
analytics yeah
maybe like thinking ahead i'm also
curious like we have heard like three
very compelling uh applications right
like in healthcare in human interaction
in business analytics uh i'm curious if
someone wanted to contribute to these
research directions uh to really good
like do a deep dive on causal ml right
like how
can we can we get some tips from from
the experts on causal element on how can
one uh contribute to this direction
uh maybe we'll start with daniel
yeah i i mean one one practical way is
is is where um as i mentioned trying to
enable people to be able to
work with um the types of simulators
that we're developing to
to build data sets with different types
of of causal relationships and and
it was interesting in what justin said
about you know
multiple modalities that's something
where um i think there's this huge scope
for kind of investigation because
as you increase um
the number of dimensions uh in in your
data
you're gonna introduce many you know
potential confounders and so um these
simulators they have a lot of modalities
or a lot of dimensions to them in terms
of what can be controlled um you know
whether it's you know weather conditions
in the environment or the behaviors of
the vehicles or pedestrians or
um
you know all of these types of things
and so
there's any number of potential
ways that you could use that to generate
uh novel data sets so that that's one
you know very practical way um but i
think you know as a whole uh there's
we're really just scratching the surface
of of creating i think models that can
learn
um
uh that really can learn the
structure
and then think about the downstream
applications that that then enables in
in the types of
applications that we're working in which
is is kind of looking and
looking at modeling and understanding
human behavior and environments and how
people interact with machines so um i
think there's there's just a
real opportunity here to
to develop new models that that have
not not just learned simple
relationships between
um edges in a graph for instance but um
can make those um
much more interpretable for people
and
and also just enable more
people in the community to to kind of
leverage the types of tools that we're
trying to build here
so if i'm hearing correctly that means
i i shouldn't be thinking of this as we
are just getting data sets out of these
rich simulations and then we can apply
end to end deep learning or deep
reinforcement learning or something like
that and
just say go it's done it's like you
actually believe that there is
also causality in the methods that are
being applied to these data sets that
can extract the structure
and and and reason about the world uh
i'm curious like uh javier uh like just
just now in daniel's response like the
question of uh interpretable and
explainable
uh solutions also came up and i'm sure
that the healthcare domain must have uh
many instances of that need uh
speaking to the broader question also of
uh how does one contribute to this very
gnarly problem of
learning for health
yeah abs absolutely um so in in the
health domain
um you need your algorithms to be
completely transparent um because you
you want
you want your algorithms to be applied
they they will need they will need to be
approved by some entity and it should be
completely clear why they are making
certain predictions and or or making
certain certain decisions um
so yeah the the point of
having interpretable models is is is key
in the in the health domain and a way to
start building that and that builds on
top of the
question of how to collaborate uh to do
uh course on demand in the healthcare
domain i think something something that
is key is uh
to
have a very open attitude towards
sitting down with the expert in the
health problem that you want to that you
want to solve and to develop a
communication strategy that makes you to
understand the details of the problems
and not not be afraid of discussing that
over and over until you you get a common
a common understanding and for instance
something that i have experienced in the
in the past is that um
using causal graphs and
to develop a common
understanding of the common language
with someone who is a biologist someone
who is uh who is a who is a doctor who
may not be used to think
in terms of a causal inference methods
per se but
people who have a very
deep understanding of the problem
thinking about causal inferences
drawing a graph and start reasoning and
and decorating the graphs in the in the
previous steps that i was sawing before
as you collect more data and you
decorate your hypotheses is key to to to
get uh to a point where you can have a
successful algorithm that you can
interpret that
everyone is
is happy with uh i would say that that's
key you know you know you know the
collaboration that we that we have
uh so maybe just a final round of
closing remarks right like um so maybe
uh we'll have time for
a couple of sentences on your
future looking perspective on
on this entire research field and what
it can do for the world
um justin do you want to go first yeah
let me uh have a quick briefing so i
think i have two uh keywords so
regarding the data analytics so the
first keyword is democratizing so
many people are still not aware the
power and the
sensitivity of leveraging causal
techniques
and then another keyword is expert users
versus non-expert users so in recent
years a lot of the non-expert users
still have the strong willingness to
consume the data analysis tools and how
to provide the reasonable reasonable and
friendly output yet scientifically to
these users is still an opportunity
thanks
daniel
yeah
kind of looping back to the beginning i
think there's
lots of potential in
um how how humans interact with with ai
systems um
in the real world
for causal inference and causal modeling
and
what one thing that's been done in the
past in in this domain has been you know
experimenting with learning causal
relationships and for instance physical
models um you know having having an
algorithm learn the physics um but what
happens when we're trying to learn for
instance social physics where there's
you know much less well-defined rules
and those rules can change depending on
context and things like that
so
that's what excites me there's a i think
a lot of questions there about how we do
that uh but i think this is going to be
something that's integral to
building safe um
you know embodied situated intelligence
um
like self-driving vehicles or you know
many other things beyond that
i completely agree and have you you have
the final word
yeah
the
this has been mentioned before but i i
would say safety and and transparency i
think these are these are key in the in
the healthcare domain uh to make sure
that we can help with our algorithms
whether that's uh
helping a doctor to make a decision or
helping someone uh hospital
about how the hospital should be
organized and this is this is key for
everything that we need to do
excellent and with that thank you all
for joining us uh in this panel uh
thanks javier daniel justin uh for a
very provocative view of the future and
how causa limbo can get us there thank
you